et le pauvre kenji il croyait qu'il
allait faire un kiff avait en fait
babar big flo et oli réunis sur un bail
c'est jamais très bon à la regarder mon
frérot je t'explique quelque chose c'est
que moi j'ai un kill dans la vie c'est
que quand tu kiffes j'ai envie de te
faire qui fait tout le temps tu vas voir
j'étais préparé une surprise et déçue
que la torpille vite fait au lit elle
chantait son pote j'espère tu vas en
tout cas ce qu'elle a dans la voiture là
il ya 80% des ventes de disques en
france il faut qu'on en dise un truc
dis moi on m'a emmené dans un endroit et
tout ce que tu nous prends mais tu que
tu chanteras quelques soient les
circonstances quoi qui va du chant c'est
vrai ouais ben vas-y je vous promets
ban a dit si vous êtes une 10e fois
saluer fera pas d inquiéter zaki pour
kenji ont fait ça quand dans les avions
ouais il faut que tu m'aides ça allait
très au fait nous confiance parce que je
voulais ça c'est qu'on a très loin mais
la quoi qu'il arrive ils sont une chance
quelque chose précise pas la date c'est
inacceptable
à lire une partie à l'éthique et les
gars je vous vois pas j'ai envie de la
vivre vraiment la peine devant l'autel
[Musique]
ça y est les gaffes à ta tête
vas-y là tu es là tu as la voiture vim
[Musique]
vraiment près romont kenzy peut enlever
ça appartient de cascadeur mais ba ba
pour le coup champions vous êtes près
tout le monde les gas salut et prévôt
allez ma barbe des prix bas
était chicago may
tandis que j'y vais même pas peur on
évoque par les oies ont servi des frères
alors tu as réussi à chanter eux c'était
compliqué ça fait les pères je flippe et
mon frère tu vas essayer toi aussi t'as
pas le choix
franchement en vrai la vérité c'est ça
me fait peur la rencontre vous étiez sur
12 ou alors c'est mentalement alors tu
restes avec toi oui mais pas derrière
à toute à tout de suite le tremplin je
sais pas quel mois ferme et ça ça donne
pas droit la clé pour lille est sur la
piste
pire il fait pour toi etc pour que de
lire ma [ __ ]
m me remplace le bidon quoi on est là et
on dépasse pas une surprise pour kenji
la wafa mer
on y fait attention
[Musique]
tiago jamais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la route
et un dernier serait pourtant tu vois ça
on va s'en servir
[Musique]
avec
pour
oui
je n'ai même pas essayé de chanter quand
j'ai vu qu'on sait apporter de plus en
plus en vue c'est avec houleux devant
fallon t'as pas vu me devant une
location en tout cas voilà très très
belle expérience
merci baba d'un grand boubou magnifique
je relève aux bisous j'espère que ça va
plaire à tous ces défis avec un 10 jours
à embrasser réfère aux buts revient très
fort et qui joue toujours le jeu qui
sont formidables et que voilà que j'aime
énormément tout comme kenji sont des
artistes
voilà avec un coeur immense
[Musique]